un dernier coup d'oeil à son appartement
quelques minutes avant de l'abandonner
le coeur lourd Alexander le sait restait
pourraient lui coûter sa vie
tout le temps nuit et jour des missiles
sont tombés sur des maisons les fenêtres
ont toutes explosé
régulières ces frappes russes obligent
donc des milliers du crinien à évacuer à
l'image de cet homme âgé et départ trois
volontaires car incapables de se
déplacer seul
dans le minibus qui emmène le petit
groupe à la gare l'émotion est vive pour
cette femme consciente qu'elle vient de
laisser une partie de sa vie derrière
elle
sur le quai une personne handicapée est
prise en charge elle s'appelle Lydia et
depuis deux semaines elle n'a plus
aucune nouvelle de son fils soldat
je sais mon fils est sur le front depuis
4 ans
c'est ce qui a causé mon AVC je suis
très inquiète pour lui
ces combats autour de bar mouth durent
depuis 5 mois maintenant de la même des
forces ukrainiennes ils sont
particulièrement féroces les russes
ayant défini la prise de la ville comme
un objectif stratégique mais pour
l'instant les hommes de Kiev résistent
même si plusieurs localités de la région
seraient tomber ces derniers jours dans
l'escarcelle de Moscou